[Musica]
Perché approcciarmi a questo tema ha
acceso una serie di dubbi sul come
affrontare la tolc
mi sono chiesto se la chiave con cui
interpretare questo tema fosse
esclusivamente progettuale ma ho avuto
paura di scadere in qualcosa di estetico
futuribile ma dello scarso
contributi in termini di contenuto ho
deciso allora di concentrarmi su ciò che
sta alla base di ogni pensiero
architettonico che è la risoluzione di
una necessità umana
le visioni di cui parla il titolo della
Talk sono proprio questo sono oggetti
concreti cui ci appoggeremo per creare
una civiltà utopica fatta anche in
qualche modo di speranza verso un futuro
diverso
quando ho ricevuto l'invito a parlare di
quale potrebbe essere la visione di un
architetto riguardo un pianeta gemello
una Terra Vergine per una progettazione
che parte da zero nel reimmaginarsi una
civiltà umana che lì abiterà
ho deciso di prendere le cose molto alla
lontana quindi ho zoomato indietro e
sono partito da qui
[Musica]
una delle cose con cui è sempre stato
difficile per me confrontarmi sia dal
punto di vista razionale che dal punto
di vista emotivo e la sconfinata
grandezza del Cosmo che è talmente
grande da far fatica a trovarci un senso
a volte la galassia che ci ospita la Via
Lattea conta circa 200 miliardi di
stelle e circa 100 miliardi di pianeti
e il numero di Galassi all'interno
dell'universo è difficilissimo da
stimare Ma si pensa sia attorno ai 170
miliardi di unità e la possibilità di
trovare un esopianeta che possa ospitare
forme di vita complessa esiste
concretamente ed esiste anche una
formula matematica in grado di darci un
numero e l'equazione di Drake che
afferrante di una formula estremamente
complessa ci dice che esistono circa 10
miliardi di possibili civiltà
tecnologicamente avanzate e quindi 10
miliardi di possibili esopianeti che
sono in grado di ospitarle questo
soltanto nella Via Lattea quindi
ci ossessioniamo da tempi ancestrali
sulla ricerca dell'altro da noi per
sfuggire a quel senso tutto umano che ci
attanaglia quando ci soffermiamo davvero
a pensare alla nostra condizione
universale che è molto specifica siamo
coscienti su un pianeta scagliato a
folle velocità all'interno del nero
assoluto e consapevole che prima o poi
questo pianeta cesserà di esistere per
le leggi cosmiche che in realtà ne hanno
permesso la nascita della vita miliardi
di anni fa
ci sosteniamo Allora anche sulla ricerca
di una nuova casa che possa essere in
grado di ospitarci nel momento in cui le
cose dovessero andare male su quella che
abitino in questo momento
esisterà un altro pianeta in grado di
ospitare una civiltà complessa con il
Sapiens
le distanze non sono della nostra Ma la
matematica ci dice appunto che la
possibilità esiste Dobbiamo soltanto
trovarlo questo posto però per capire
quale posto sia il migliore Per
ospitarci per essere colonizzato
Dobbiamo capire innanzitutto che cosa si
intende per civilizzazione la grafica
che vedete le spalle è una grafica in
cui si susseguono lungo
le migliaia di anni che ci hanno visto
Calcare il la superficie del pianeta
diverse civiltà Ognuno di essa è
caratterizzata da una serie di sistemi
che la caratterizzano proprio come
asseverabile a categorie di civiltà sono
la capacità di elaborare un codice di
comunicazione in grado di permettere
l'interazione tra individui la capacità
di costruire ripari siano essi mobili o
permanenti e organizzarli a formare
delle sovrastrutture in grado di
sostenere un'esistenza comune il talento
nel realizzare delle Infrastrutture di
contatto proprio questi insegnamenti per
permettere lo spostamento di individui
informazioni e prodotti
l'elaborazione di una gerarchia di
potere che controlli questo complesso
sistema di interazione
la tecnologia per produrre un surplus di
prodotti di sostegno alla vita che
svincoli gli individui dell'indigenza
del sopravvivere permetta al sistema
lavoro diciamo di costituirsi
nell'andamento dei colori corrisponde a
momenti di crescita e di dilatazione a
momenti di crisi di contrazione a
momenti di brusca interruzione
le civiltà collassano e collassano
perché collasso di sistemi di supporto
che ne costituiscono le fondamenta
l'esercizio di immaginazione che ho
provato a fare è stato prendere alcune
delle caratteristiche appena descritte
quelle più attinente ciò che faccio
nella vita l'architetto ed immaginare
come potremmo declinarle qualora
trovassimo davvero un pianeta gemello in
grado di supportare la nostra vita
la microgenerazione di energia
rinnovabile potrebbe essere un buon modo
per sostenere al tempo stesso piccoli
insediamenti locali ma anche una
sovrastruttura energetica che alimenti
un sistema ben più complesso e
stratificato dove ciascuno possa
connettersi disconnettersi
all'occorrenza coltivando un
Indipendenza energetica che abbiamo
capito soltanto ultimamente quanto sia
fondamentale
non è soltanto l'indipendenza energetica
rappresentare una delle chiavi
che deve essere cercata per colonizzare
questo nuovo pianeta gemello anche la
produzione di cibo dovrebbe essere
ripensata la produzione di cibo lì
potrebbe essere ripensata nell'ottica di
svincolarsi all'occorrenza da un sistema
globale per abbracciare una produzione
più locale più ridotta e soprattutto in
grado di sopportare eventuali collassi
di una macro supply chain che potrebbe
essere più fragile di quello che ci
aspettiamo
la capacità di resistere a questi shock
è una caratteristica che dovrebbe essere
cercata nella progettazione di
qualsivoglia nuova abitazione sia la più
piccola che la più grande e gli Shop
potrebbero essere di qualsiasi tipo
temperature elevate siccità eventi
climatici violenti imprevedibili
infezioni virali che sarebbe meglio
tenere alla larga quindi costruire
staccati da terra e semplicemente
un'esperienza un modo per riassumere un
espediente grafico per parlare della
caratteristica principe che dovrebbero
avere ciascuno di questi insegnamenti
Ovvero la resilienza
non sempre ostinarsi a restare nel posto
in cui siamo nati e cresciuti
rappresenta la scelta migliore a volte
per circostanze imposte si potrebbe
essere costretti a spostarsi E allora se
si parte da zero nella progettazione di
un pianeta gemello perché non progettare
insediamenti che siano in grado di
seguirci nei nostri spostamenti
recuperando anche lì quello spirito
nomade che ci ha contraddistinto per per
millenni questo nel caso gli
insegnamenti fossero piccoli
insediamenti e sarebbe una condizione
chiaramente iniziale a tendere Noi
dovremmo provare il modo di costruire
degli insediamenti sempre più densi per
evitare il consumo di suolo per renderli
migliori dal punto di vista della
pedonalizzazione per aumentare la
flessibilità degli spazi di vita per
abbattere i costi dei trasporti e
soprattutto per renderli energeticamente
più efficienti
l'energia continuerà a essere un
problema anche sul pianeta Gemello la
produzione l'approvvigionamento
energetico rappresenteranno un
grattacapo anche lì E qui che entra in
gioco la macro rete di cui abbiamo
parlato all'inizio
è un sistema di stazioni di generazione
in grado di produrre energia continua a
differenza delle rinnovabili
in abbondanza pulita come le rinnovabili
un'infrastruttura di generazione a
fusione nucleare Semmai riusciremo a
trovare il modo di farla
implementazione di un sistema di
connessione ancora più fluido aiuterebbe
ad abbattere le barriere linguistiche
culturali che ci dividono aiutandoci ad
essere in grado di coordinarci
all'interno di una biosfera sconosciuta
e talvolta imprevedibile
la creazione di un palinsesto di
cultura ci aiuterà a riunirci a fattor
comune e a non perdere di vista chi
siamo da dove veniamo simboli
monumentali manifestazioni concrete
della nostra capacità intellettuale
creativa saranno un antidoto contro le
difficoltà che potremmo trovare nel caso
riuscissimo davvero a colonizzare un
pianeta gemello
l'integrazione fluida tra individui
individui tra individuo e nuove forme di
intelligenza artificiale ci aiuteranno a
sopravvivere In un ecosistema
inizialmente ostile cui potremmo
adattarci solo se saremo in grado di
dialogare operativamente politicamente e
solo se saremo in grado di sfruttare al
meglio la capacità di immagazzinamento
dei dati che le macchine possono
permetterci di raggiungere
quella che avete visto è l'ultima
visione della mia personale versione di
un pianeta gemello e proprio parlando di
intelligenza artificiale queste immagini
sono state generate a fronte di un mio
input testuale una mia descrizione di
ciò che volevo fosse l'anima
dell'immagine stessa da un software gay
che trasforma visuals testing visuals vi
sembrerà che questi oggetti siano Sì
futuristici ma non così lontani da ciò
che siamo abituati a vedere sulla terra
i paesaggi stessi sono una versione
inasprita è più difficile di ciò che
troviamo proprio qui
queste immagini sono liberamente
ispirate al lavoro dell'artista Simon's
Talent Hack che ha fatto del retro
Futurismo la cifra contante del suo
stile le immagini che avete visto
viaggiano in bilico tra speranza e
distopia c'è Qualcosa di colorato di
vibrante Ma c'è anche un po' di
sofferenza un po' di solitudine ma
soprattutto c'è qualcosa di familiare
sembrano la terra
[Musica]
questo perché fondamentalmente quando ci
approcciamo questo tema potrebbe essere
forse utile tirare fuori il paradosso di
fermi che riguarda la presenza di
civiltà aliene all'interno dell'universo
e può essere esteso anche alla
possibilità di trovare pianeti gemelli e
realmente in grado di sostenere la vita
sulla loro superficie se ci sono davvero
tutte queste possibilità Dove sono le
altre terre vale la pena allora
invertire la rotta rispetto allo zoom
out che abbiamo fatto all'inizio della
tolc e potrebbe essere invece molto più
importante concentrarci su ciò che
abbiamo di incredibilmente vicino le
visioni che abbiamo visto prima sono
delle visioni estrapolate da un futuro
non troppo lontano qui sulla Terra e
poserebbero essere delle strategie per
sopravvivere su un pianeta che sta
cominciando ad assomigliare sempre meno
a quello a cui siamo abituati
chiunque sia nato Nella seconda metà del
secolo scorso non ha avuto la
possibilità di fare esperienza delle
condizioni climatiche che hanno permesso
la nascita e la prosperità dei Sapiens
sulla terra di fatto noi esseri umani
stiamo già vivendo la nostra vita su un
pianeta gemello che è il pianeta
dell'antropocene e il pianeta in cui il
sistema di supporto climatico alla vita
è già cambiato
mitigazione adattamento sono le uniche
strategie che possiamo applicare per
riuscire a continuare ad esistere sul
nostro vero reale solo che pianeta
gemello l'unico che conosciamo davvero
fino ad oggi
l'essere umano vive di storia e dovremmo
imparare a da ciò che è stato fatto fino
ad ora per costruire una storia
alternativa a quella che stiamo
percorrendo oggi Grazie a tutti